people who wait for a filmmaking career
will never have one without of course
naming any names
can you think of some people in your
life who are very talented
but have been waiting and maybe it
frustrates you
maybe you see the opportunity in front
of them
but they won't take it for whatever
reason um yeah absolutely mostly
colleagues i won't even say friends but
just people that you run into
but what i've unders what i've come to
realize
is that particularly those filmmakers
that come out of film school
like you're not going to have a crew of
30 on your first your next film
you know they come out with these great
thesis films and they want to get their
feature made
but in this in this age of independent
filmmaking
no one's going to give you a million
dollars to do your your thesis film
and when i don't see them working or
trying to to
kind of start from scratch whether it's
a short film
whatever it is to continue to continue
to do the craft until you get that
i'm not saying it's not possible but i'm
really blown away by
filmmakers i know that have a great
thesis film from film school and are
waiting
to make their feature film i'm like why
aren't you doing something now
you know i don't want to shoot something
on my phone i don't want to shoot
something
with a with a three-person crew i'm like
what are you waiting for but it's it's
not a uh
it's not something i can tell people
they have to figure that out their own
but if you've been
10 years now and i know filmmakers that
are 10 years out of film school
still thinking they're gonna get three
million dollars to produce their first
film based off their thesis
what do you think that is is it that
they think that
they're at a different status level they
don't need to do that they want people
to
they want to have investors i think it's
a combination of that and also it's a
combination of
people in this industry i think everyone
looks at their
trajectory going like this you know and
it doesn't you've started with a thesis
and you have a crew of 30 and you have
all those millions of dollars worth of
equipment
that the school provides for you you get
out do you really want to shoot your
your short film on your iphone the ones
that work do
you know but the ones that because
that's that's ego
you know and in my experience having
done as much as i've done
what i've found is there's certain film
schools and i've hired film school
students
you know and but the one i will say i
won't say the ones where they have the
least discipline but the ones with the
most discipline
have come from the los angeles film
school they have come with a discipline
to work and it didn't matter how good
their thesis film was
if my crew was smaller whatever they
wanted to work they wanted to learn
and they wanted to produce i know
there's a lot of backlash on millennials
that oh they don't want to work and
things like that
i haven't always seen that i've seen it
it can be across many
different you know generation acts i've
seen different work ethics
do you think there's is it generational
or is it
um a mindset that it's definitely a
mindset
i don't find it generational at all if
this is what you want to do you're going
to do it
and you're going to do it as long as
often as you possibly can
the thing i say to people who want to be
writers you got to be writing every day
if you want to be a director or
filmmaker you should be trying to make
something or shoot something every month
every week if you can but at least every
month
you know it's a craft it's like building
a deck
right your first deck you build is not
going to maybe be as
as fancy or as good but the more you do
it the better you get at it
and filmmaking is no different so i
don't really subscribe to that
philosophy as well i'm waiting for this
i'm waiting for the right money i'm
writing i'm waiting for the right people
right
no i'm not a subscriber of that you have
to just kind of
go forward if that's all you're banking
on though is that all you have is your
one script that you want to make perfect
um you're going to have a difficult time
do you think the diy mindset because
there's certain people that are just
like
really self-generate like they just they
rely on themselves
they don't expect any handout and they
just want to do something themselves
whereas there's others that maybe
they've had more coddling
or whatever it is you think that there's
a clash do you think they clash
sometimes those two mindsets
only on a panel
um yeah because to me it just comes down
to the work can you produce
you know uh so it it can to that sen i
think
you we we there are certain filmmakers
we follow and we see their career and we
try to model
i think filmmakers try to model their
careers after other filmmakers
that's not something i've ever done um
i've never looked at someone and said
this is how i'm going to do it like they
did
you know or i'm going to do this and
this is what's going to happen my thing
has always just been
how do i get my stuff made right now you
know and
if i wrote a 10 million dollar script i
would have it
but that wouldn't be the first thing i
would try to get made i would have
a 50 000 script i would have a 10 000
script
i'd have different things what do i have
what can i do right now
you know and then if that does take what
do i have
back here that's ready to go
while we were setting up you said you
had a couple friends that are always
calling you for filmmaking advice or
whatever
which prompted an idea yeah i
well they both was in the same week they
were calling me up saying can you meet
me
so we could talk about some things i'm
doing my film and i need some advice
sure man so
i would always usually just try to give
advice based on a story or an experience
not necessarily this is what you have to
do because every film is going to be
different
and in that week these two friends of
mine like you really should write a book
about all your experiences man you've
done a lot
and i was in a place back then where i'm
like yeah i've done a lot but i'm not
where i
want to be um so who's going to listen
who's going to care
and they're like well we would we would
care like he's like there's a lot of
people
that you would inspire just knowing that
you're still doing it even though you're
not
at that place that you want to be at but
that you still continue to work
and you always have a lot of you have a
lot of experience so why not put it into
a book form
and i said well we'll see and then so i
kind of played with the idea for a
little while and then about three years
ago
i got with a writing group and started
sharing some chapters with them and they
really encouraged me to to keep pursuing
it because
it is quite a journey i'm not a
connected guy
i'm not a hollywood guy i've i grew up
in wilmington it wasn't a place that
bred great artists there was nothing
really inspiring around me
um i just loved movies that and i
i thought i wanted to be an actor but
but i found that i was a director
and so when i made that change things
nothing happened for me as an actor but
as soon as i made that change to be a
director things started happening
so um so yeah that's kind of a long
answer but yeah i started writing a book
called stereotypical
my filmmaking journey from the harbor to
hollywood and it should be out in
october
uh and hopefully people will get a value
from it
when those two friends sort of threw
that idea out there
where do you start because i'm sure we
all see our life in one way
and other people can see it from another
i think it's either really interesting
or whatever
how do you like well i had initially
started
at the theater academy that i met my
wife at because that's when i first
started directing you had to take a
directing class there and
my attitude was so like against it like
i didn't want to direct a play i was
there to act
right and i found a
way to do this project for the directing
class i just half-assed and
my i found the letter for my grade on
that
that the the teacher wrote to me is
basically saying you show the most
promise
of any person in this classroom as a
director he's i
but you haven't done the work i can't
give you you know a grade other than
this
but he's i'm really disappointed you
think and talk and speak like a director
and i was like and i was like insulted
by the thing i'm an actor
and um and so i've ran into that teacher
on a few occasions and
you know i'm obviously directing a lot
more now so and i don't act at all in my
stuff
for the most part i'll have a cameo here
and there um
but uh that's where i started and then
and you know it's weird when you start
writing something that personal other
it triggers other memories and then i
remember producing
something when i was seven years old um
in my garage it was a show
for the kids in the neighborhood and so
that's where i started
the book with uh how that came about
that was the first time i had produced
anything and i i was in it
and the trials and tribulations of that
of acts
quitting and then coming in at the last
minute and i had to do everything
um but it happened you know i actually
produced a little show
like the little rascals that's that was
my inspiration the little rascals
they always they had such a can-do
attitude about anything they had no one
they had their own fire department you
know what i mean so
there was like things like that like it
was that kind of spirit to it and i try
to
keep that spirit in when i'm up against
the uh
some great odds and producing something
where do you go to uh write these
chapters
are you writing at home um i used to no
i used to go
to the aroma cafe in studio city
the reason that place was important to
me was when i moved from wilmington to
studio city i was paying 400
a month for a studio on that street on
tahunga
and i would get home late night
bartending i'd walk my dog at 1 30 in
the morning which you couldn't do in
wilmington where i grew up
and i that little cafe was there and i
would go there to write
and there was a sense that i had made it
already
i was out of wilmington and i was living
in studio city a place that was so
hollywood it
called itself studio city and i was
writing and i just
at that point i felt like i had made it
and so that place
was that for a while but now i kind of
bounce around
we moved out of that area um about three
years ago
and so now i just bounce sometimes it's
at home you know
uh it just depends i carry a notebook
with me i'm always writing
so and it's just translating my notes um
but i will write pretty much anywhere i
can i'll take my laptop with me or i'll
have a notebook with me all the time no
matter what
and when you started writing those
chapters did it
reframe your life for you in any way did
you look at yourself differently
um it helped me get out of the place i
was in um
after doing my seventh film and
i was kind of wounded after my seventh
film
because i had stopped and started so
many times even before that and then
nothing happened with that one and so i
was kind of like why am i still drudging
along
which is what i felt like i was doing
and
all the negative experiences of getting
seven feature films were
like kind of like right here whoops i
don't miss it right here
and as i was writing the book and
speaking of the experiences
the negative stuff was very small it was
all really fun and inspiring and
and and um a reminder to myself
of why i was doing this so the book was
very cathartic for me in that sense
um one of the chapters is on 2010
at the beginning of that year my my
four-year-old was hit by a car and he
survived i always
stressed that he survived and he's he's
doing well he's he's
14 now um but that's how my years
started and it ended with me losing my
house
so and in that time i released my third
feature film
but two films that i was counting on the
financing fell through and that's why i
was
i lost my house because i was counting
on those two films
and i gambled pretty big um
and i thought i was gonna lose my family
at that time but luckily the
the wife um was uh very supportive even
in that time
again just setting up i just jokingly
said something that you
said should be on a t-shirt and that is
call me when you make your second call
me when you make your second yeah
someone does the first film i'm like
okay give me a call when you do your
second film
you know because if after your first
film you say oh man yeah i gotta go
through that again
then you're a filmmaker you know but
i say that because in the films that
i've done
a lot of my lead actors have gone off a
lot of my stuff's ensemble right
so a few of my leads almost all my leads
of all my feature films had gone off to
write and direct their own films because
i had shown them
how to pull the rabbit out of the hat
for a little money
because at that time no one thought you
could make a movie for fifty thousand
dollars
and i was doing that and i was getting
them at blockbuster i was getting them
on redbox and getting them on netflix
so these actors would go off and use my
connections to do
their thing but no and some of them did
it right in the sense that they
started their process some of them
didn't do it so right and they just
copied my process
but none of them went off to make a
second film
you know so i always have told actors in
particular
and some of them had asked me to direct
their thing and i'm like why are you
doing this well i really want to
showcase
my talent with this like okay that's not
a reason
it's a vanity project it's not something
i'm interested in i go if there's
nothing personal
then why why are you gonna do this
because that's gonna wreak of
vanity as soon as you put it out there
so and most of them
were and they never went to go do a
second one
because it's a lot of you gotta i mean
look your audience knows you know what
it takes
to make a feature film right and if
you're just doing it to showcase your
acting talent
um it's it's that's a hard thing to
motivate
to keep you motivated throughout the
process you know
and then also after you get past
releasing it and your friends and family
are supportive
where is it now you know did it go on to
get distribution did it go on to a
festival that
you know wasn't especially what i call
specialty film festival you know where
you know everybody involved and they're
like
they want to support the film and that's
great but um
not very few of them have gone to go do
a second actually none of them have gone
on to do a second feature
and most of the people i know that have
that thought they wanted to be
filmmakers
after the first one that was it for them
and they're just like i don't know how
you did it how do you do it raising your
family
and do it i said well i enjoy both i
don't i
love making movies i love being a family
guy i love
my being a husband i love being a dad so
to me
it's not i don't want to say the words
hard because it is
hard but it's not labored
and so you have a family you have two
children and you also work
yes yeah so you haven't been on a dry
spell although
i will say this month is the first month
in a while
i'm making more money as a writer
director than i am in my job
and so that was that was a really good
way to start august
so this is always yeah so um but uh
but yeah i have to i have to maintain my
my financial responsibilities to my
family but the job that i have
um allows me to do both it allows me to
keep pursuing
my as a i have a flexibility in that
um and so i'm able to provide for my
family and
and and do that and pursue filmmaking
you know that's helped me keep my sanity
have you ever wanted to have a
non-flexible job because i know there's
always that bait
like should i take this like more steady
or not even steady paycheck but
no i i'm not a nine to five guy
i'm not a nine to five guy i knew that
very early on um
yeah i would have friends that would say
you know i don't know how you do it
without the security of
you know retirement or health care that
luckily my wife's job she has the health
care so we don't have to worry about
that but
i said there is no guarantees man like
there are no guarantees
i'm sure a lot of people that worked a
lot of these financial institutions that
have gone
gone down all thought they had security
there's no such thing as security
there's no security in being an artist
you know and
somehow we we we pay the the bills every
month
and still pursue it's just having
courage to do that
most people don't and i don't blame them
but you have to have that
if you want to pursue your art and
there's a lot of jobs in la that are
like these flexible jobs that
actually pay a decent wage you know
oh yeah there's all these micro econ
people make it work and make it hustle
you know it's i always say i go look if
you come to la to
pursue acting or film making or whatever
your passion is
if it's important to you you'll find a
way if it's not you'll find an excuse
do you regret not making films earlier
in your career
or do you think it all happened in the
right time no i you know that's a hard
one to answer
because i feel like i'm not i'm not a
believer of luck but i am a believer in
timing
and i will say i feel like my career has
been
a combination of being too early or too
soon
um i wish i had i wish i was that guy
that was making movies at seven years
old you know
so by the time i had gotten to 26 when i
made my first film i would already have
been a skilled filmmaker
but i'm starting at 26 just learning so
in that sense yes but um
where my life the trajectory of my
personal life i don't know would have
been the same
you know when i was in high school uh
there was a huge omen
uh when i was in high school there was a
teacher there
i wasn't particularly good at anything
at that point with two of my best
friends we had a cable access show
and i would help them with that and the
teacher told them and i went to a
predominantly affluent white private
school
i didn't grow up there but that's where
i went to school so
one of their counselors said usc is
doing this thing as film school
introduction
do you guys want to go and they're like
yeah ken you want to go with us i go
yeah i'll go with you guys
so we all went together and the odd
thing was like these were two white guys
i was only latino pretty much in the
school
and we go to this usc thing and it turns
out it was for latino students
so it's the first time they were the
only two white guys in this entire
group and then i was there and there was
a huge
like the universe telling me go to usc
film school or do something
this way and i just wasn't in the right
frame line i was a very angry and
insecure person at that time
and but i look back on that and i tell
that story in the book too that
there was a huge thing right there and
we had to get into
groups and do pitches and i was just in
my element and my two buddies were like
man we didn't know you even had like
ideas and all this
i didn't know either man i just felt so
i felt like i had a community
you know and and i was being validated
not
and i was never in search of that but
there it was
but i was just too um
like i said i was in a very negative
space in high school throughout the
duration so i just wasn't open to it but
had i done that i wouldn't have met my
wife and that was you know
that's the luckiest thing that's ever
happened to me you know i've had no luck
in film
everything's been through hard work and
just sheer will
but meeting my wife was pure luck you
know
and having that happen so i don't have
regrets in that sense
you know do i wish i had more experience
going in my first film
yes but i don't know that i would have
had the same
same uh journey you know and i'm
i look back on my journey especially
writing the book and i'm really kind of
proud of it do you ever
feel thankful for the anger you said you
had in high school because that
prompted you to want to tell really
powerful stories that aren't vanity
projects no because it wasn't
high school was very um
uh how do i say it was like a
non-creative time in my life it just was
uh it's not something i'd even look back
fondly it wasn't until i got to the
theater academy which was a year after i
graduated high school i went to this
acting academy where i was able to break
myself down
and it was all for acting but it helped
me rebuild myself
and be somebody who was creative and who
had things to say
so that anger outside of high school
turned into i'm not happy how do i
change this
let me try this and then go to an acting
academy where you're the normal one
you know i mean so that was but i was
just so inspired by everybody there
because everyone was so brave
there were people there that were broke
you know pursuing their dream and so
that place uh was such a great place for
me creatively
to learn the language of acting which
helped me with actors to this day i mean
i'm i'm proud to say i'm an
actor's director i get that comment from
the actors i work with all the time
they all say you know you just speak our
language that's because i know the
language i went to an acting academy i'm
a classically trained actor who
doesn't act i make movies but i know how
to speak with them and i think going
back to an earlier question you said
that's the advantage i think i have over
film school students who don't learn
that
you know because it's to me it's the art
of communication
you know you can have this vision you
could have this talent but if you can't
communicate it
you got to be able to communicate it to
your crew and to your cast that's my
talent
you know when you have two kids that
have asked you a million questions a day
growing up i don't have all those
answers but on set
i have every answer when that acting
teacher
gave you that note that or wherever they
gave you that grade
and said like you would make a great
director out of anybody in this class
and you said you were hurt by it or
offended
well i was i was just so like no i'm an
actor i'm not a director
you know like i didn't i didn't i took
it like a negative
you know i didn't again there was a
second time the universe is telling me
hey ken look you're you're a director
you're not an actor
you know and me ignoring that you know
and it wasn't until
i got out of the academy and me and the
wife
were going out on things that were very
uninspiring and
there weren't a lot of latinos producing
anything or writing anything or
even there weren't that many of us in
terms of actors so we're like what do we
do we just went to school for this
we started writing directing and
producing our own plays
and that was at a necessity but i was
starting to enjoy
directing more than i was being on the
stage
you know because directing my instincts
were just very fluid and i knew exactly
what to do and when to do it i knew how
to communicate something i knew how to
block something
when i was an actor i was constantly
judging you know is this
is this genuine is this authentic is
this am i you know i wasn't
i didn't know how to get there as an
actor you know
um but i knew how to get other actors
there
can you just give us some practical tips
on um maybe you call it the actors
language or the director's language with
actors
for me it starts with trust and it
starts with the audition process
i don't use casting directors i've done
seven feature films never use the
casting director i do not find the
casting process
brings out the best i think it it
rewards good auditioners but not good
actors
because they're two different things
right there there are actors that are
good auditioners and they're actors that
are good actors
and they're terrible auditioners my
process eliminates that
um because someone could blow an
audition but if i see something if i see
their humanity and i don't mean them
struggling
with being nervous i mean just there's
something
deeper that they want to express and
they can't do it in the two or three
pages
i will bring them back for a call back
and i will put actors together and see
how they
how much they give each other and that's
normally how i how i will work an
audition especially in a call back i run
it like an acting workshop
i let the actors play and then i want to
see
who can take direction but essentially
i'm trying to get who they are
and it's just part of it it's just
instinct and my business has always been
people
so and and having the intuition to go
this is going to work with this you know
and
getting them to talk to each other play
tennis with each other back and forth
because then if you have an actor comes
in fully prepared and they kill the
audition
and then i put them in a scene with
somebody and they're doing the exact
same thing they did in the audition
then i know that's all they're going to
give me and that's not enough
there has to be more i try to make the
actor feel comfortable and confident
embodying the character by using their
own
emotional experience what's the
difference between having
a big ego and a strong ego as a director
oh that's a great question um well
having a big ego comes from insecurity
right having a strong ego is being
confident in what you're doing but you
have to beat people over the head with
it
one thing i said with my latest film is
i'm not trying to beat people over the
head
with my film i'm trying to break their
heart with it
and it really comes down to approach but
it really essentially is about
it's it's like a fine line between
arrogance and confidence
right and and people know the difference
but the problem is
directors are fed they're fed that ego
on set whether they know what they're
doing or whether they don't they're fed
that because people just assume
that they know what they're doing but
for me
i don't like to manipulate actors i
don't feel i need to
manipulate actors i don't need to cause
havoc between
two people to get a performance because
the audience knows
only what i show them right here they
don't know all this
they don't need to know all that so
to me confidence is not even the right
word if there was a better word for
confidence i would just say
being able to communicate your vision
in a very clear and concise way if you
know how to do that
you don't need to you know uh
be that guy that that is flamboyant but
a director to director is one thing an
actor to a director they're never gonna
call a director on that
you know what i'm saying whether he's
arrogant or confident a director's never
get called out on that
on a professional set everyone assumes
that they're there because they're
supposed to be there
so you have this kind of advantage but
where it really starts to boil down is
how you communicate with the actors and
when my crew starts to engage
with what we're shooting and they're not
just doing a job then i know we have
something i always go by the crew
because they see a million things right
they see a million movies they're on
sets a million times but if i see them
engaging and watching the actors
performance
then i like okay well we got something
the crew is interested
we have something here you know and
they're trying they're trying to make it
better they're trying to take it just to
make it a little bit better
you know um but that is that is
essentially it i always i tell every
filmmaker i meet i go there's three
tenets i live by and i form them
by watching other directors um that that
didn't go on to do anything and one is
don't let your ego be bigger than your
career
don't make promises you can't keep
especially the cast and crew
and the last one is when it's all said
and done let her let more be said
than done lead by example you know you
can't
um especially in the social media age a
lot of people
can post anything about any everyone's a
producer everybody's this or that or the
other
but when you look beyond it is the work
there
that's what i always tell people don't
look at the surface look deeper don't be
so fooled so easily
you know you can tell the people someone
asked me recently you know this guy's a
producer and
i said if he's a producer then what does
he produce
he's like well i don't want to ask him
that it would be insulting him i go why
is that insulting him
i go you're only insulting him if he
doesn't have anything i go then you know
i go i know it feels good to have
someone go i want to help you i'm a
producer i know that feels good
but don't be fooled by that just ask
them okay what have you done
i go we get asked that question all the
time when i tell someone a filmmaker
what have you done
well i've done this this and this where
can i watch it you can watch it here
here and here
oh okay but if someone says her producer
and you go what have you produced and
they get upset and they get their ego
damaged
that's because they haven't done
anything
so don't be fooled by that what if we
took it a step
back and we see the difference between
ego
and sort of a strong sense of self in
even wanting to be a filmmaker
well i mean look you have to have
there's a certain amount of narcissism
you have to have
you know to me is about controlling that
um
because it and there's a certain amount
of
maybe even arrogance to say i'm going to
make something that people are going to
care about
so you have to have just a tiny bit of
that but more so than that
what i say is it's more of a naivety and
i think that having the naivety doing
your first film
is a strength it's not a weakness
because you don't know
what you're up against and that's a good
thing because if you knew that maybe you
would never get started
and maybe that would save you a bunch of
time heartache and money but
if this is what you want to do and you
don't have all don't know what's ahead
of you and you don't know what's what's
involved
that will drive you to the end of your
film at least your first film
and then when you get to the end of it
you may be like
wow i'm not going to do that again or
you're gonna be like
i can't wait to do that again you know
um regardless of where it goes if it
went to sundance or
it got distribution regardless if your
attitude after that is
man that was hard as hell but that was
awesome i gotta do that again
then hey there's something wrong with
you and b you're a filmmaker and
go go go you know right and it's okay to
have it be something wrong with you
because
that's what it you know it's okay
there's like degrees they say well
artists are crazy or selfish or whatever
but there's degrees
you know it doesn't have to be totally
negative in that sense it means they
want to
create something i i have a balance
because like i said i have a family and
and you know i'm one of the few you know
i'm one of the few people that i know
that has a family and has done
both but that's the other question i get
asked is well how do you do it
and you know i'll ask this do you have a
family no do you have a job no
i'm like okay you have no responsibility
you're asking me how to do it
go you go do it i go do you have one of
these and i
grabbed their phone go do it if you want
me to tell you how to make a
million dollars you want me to tell you
how to get into sundance you want me to
tell you how to get in the theater
i don't know how to do those things i go
um
but the fact that you're sitting there
asking me when you have time
and energy and a cell phone make
something
is it going to be great probably not
your first time out
but that's part of it man like you got
to do the crap to get to do some cool
stuff
you know i've done seven films not all
of them are great
you know and but the ones that aren't
great that was my fault
i did no one's to blame except me on
those ones you know but
um every one of them is a learning
experience and everyone feeds the next
one
can you paint a picture of how much work
it takes to be a filmmaker for people
watching this channel
maybe they're in that similar boat
they've gone to film school they're
waiting for this like magical producer
to come along with this check well if
you're doing your first film
and you have a producer you're lucky
enough to have a producer that's great
but you will be producing as well
like there's no getting around it you're
not going to be just directing
let's assume you didn't write the script
okay let's say you partnered up with
somebody
what you can what you can expect is just
an all-encompassing
um days of just
prepping and it's not a thing get a
camera and go shoot i mean you have to
it is a lot of preparation and
that is something that i don't get i
think gets lost a lot
you know like when i was doing marigold
my seventh film
it would be two weeks of prep for two
days of shooting
you know so it's making sure that you
have the cast and crew that you have the
insurance that you have the permits that
you have everything
and sometimes the person that could the
one the only ones gonna care the most
about it
is going to be you unless you have an
incredible budget where you're able to
pay people to care
right you're the one that's caring the
most and
you you can't drop the ball and you have
to be leading
everything you cannot be behind on
anything because
as soon as they lose confidence in you
then your first day of shooting
it's going to be a disaster you know and
um so that's the big thing you can
expect it's just a lot of prep
before depending on the the requirements
of your
of your script and your story but um
any little thing if you want it to be
done well then you're going to have to
put that time in that's not necessarily
directing
why would they lose confidence in you um
because you can tell when someone
doesn't know when they don't have
a clear vision about what you what you p
people will excuse you if you can't
communicate your vision
but they will not excuse you if you
don't have a vision your cast and your
crew
you know and that's the thing that i
always tell like you have to have a very
clear vision about what you want if you
don't know what you want
then you're in big trouble so is
that something that you learn on your
feet by going through it yeah i don't
think that's something you could be
taught
i think it's something that you have to
you have to learn by doing
and start small start small
particularly if you're a woman or a
person of color you're not going to be
given an opportunity to fail
on a major thing i've had several actors
actors contact me
on tv shows who know i'm trying to get
into tv directing
and they're like beside themselves
because some 27 year old
onset never directed anything doesn't
know what he's doing and yet he has an
opportunity
to do that and it's usually a white male
it's usually a white male
we're not going to be given those
opportunities we need to know what we're
doing
the day we're on set you know and
um and a lot of those instances the dp
is teaching them how to do their job
you know um i like working with dps
because i can learn i learn from them
you know i i that was my film school
working with dps i've been fortunate to
work with
several different ones and i learn
lenses and i learn their language
and they love it they love it because i
can speak their language
and i understand what a lens what size
lens does and what it's used for how to
move the camera
um get to know everybody's job
costume makeup everybody you know when
you're first starting out that's the
advantage you're gonna have to do all
that stuff anyway
it'll give you an appreciation for the
people who do do those things
you know um but like hair and makeup
people love me because i'm not gonna
have them go through
six or seven variations on someone's
hair i know exactly what i want i'm like
oh my god i love you you know what you
want that's what i always get from my
hair and makeup oh my god i love you you
know what you want
and i'm like yeah i'm not gonna send you
back seven times for
seven different looks only to go back to
the first thing i saw you know i know
right away
boom that's gonna work that's gonna work
let's go
sounds like having a clear vision is
very important to you that's kind of how
you
run your life really yeah you're very
like you know what you want and that's
awesome
does that translate into the stories you
want to tell
you're very clear on what you want to
tell i'm very clear on
the emotions i'm trying to get my films
to
invoke in people i'm very clear on that
um and i'm about 90 clear on how to do
that
my fourth film i'm not even going to say
the title it's
one of my most personal scripts but the
budget
i had kept having to compromise and
there were great
moments that i had to get rid of and i
didn't know on set i didn't know how to
make the adjust
the adjustment you're not gonna get this
ken we can't afford it
something that was promised to me during
the shoot so i was losing things
during the shoot you know and so that
was hard
and so for that particular film when i
saw the trailer i'm like wow we nailed
it
you know cause i had to do that try i
had that trailer cut at the very end of
production because i was using that
trailer to raise money for my next film
as soon as i got back i had another
meeting and that producer was like
so impressed that i had a trailer for
and then she saw that she's like wait
you shot that in three weeks i'm like
yeah she's like
it was a five-minute meeting boom i had
the i had the the movie
but the movie didn't do what the trailer
did
the movie didn't do what the trailer
promised and the reason why was because
i
i had to make compromises and i couldn't
make the adjustment to still get the
emotional impact of the film that i
wanted
so in pieces it works but not as a whole
so in that instance there was a clear
vision
but i wasn't able to make the adjustment
i wasn't able to and for all my other
films i was able to do that
i was able for them to say so can the
scene
we can't do it the way you want to do it
you have to do something else okay fine
i want to keep the emotion that this
scene brings let me switch it let me fix
it
let me use what we have i was able to do
that very quickly for that
film whatever for whatever reason just
wasn't able to and i think because i was
doing too much
with with so little and at your fourth
film
that's very hard you know if it's my
first film it's easy the ideas start
coming but your fourth film you're very
specific right i want this this this and
there's no
there's no compromise and then you're
compromising constantly on a daily basis
and you're just like
the the heart of that film that got
gutted
but um yeah it is you have to i think uh
one of my improv teachers at the academy
said he's like always
he was the one that taught me he's like
you always have a clear vision about
what you want
because you will subconsciously make
decisions that will lead you to that
those goals and he's been right
for a very long time so he's doesn't
mean it's going to happen when you want
it to happen
but things will start to happen and i've
had a lot of full circle moments like
that
you know and and that have given me uh
or i would run into a director a
director would help that i admired
helped me with something and i'm like i
never thought i would even meet this
person
and now they're we have emails and he's
telling me no keep going man
you know do your thing and or meeting an
actor or working with an actor that i
grew up watching
like writing the script saying this is
the actor i want we're never going to
get them but this is the actor i want
putting it out there and knowing very
clearly that's what i want
not knowing how you're going to get
there and then i get you get there those
little miracles
are so important in filmmaking it
doesn't mean though your film is special
it just has to happen for it to be made
independent filmmaking you need those
miracles
and they happen but you can't get too
impressed by them
and after you when you do your first
film you do right you're like
we weren't going to get this location we
got it for free we must be going to
sundance this film's on its way
and it's not like but no those things
happen just from
planning and putting it out there
hopefully we can do this hopefully we
can do that well let's aim for it
and more times than not those those
things have come to fruition
so you said your fourth film was very
personal to you and you feel like
for budgetary reasons or whatever it was
shortchanged do you ever see yourself
redoing it then
uh yeah i do actually um i would have to
change
change it up a little bit because the
distributor owns that movie i don't they
haven't done much with it i think it got
into target and walmart and
that was the extent of it i know they're
trying to get all my films on netflix
right now
um so i don't yeah i i think i could
revisit that but i don't know when i
made that movie at that time that's how
i was feeling
i was feeling like the main character at
that time he was in a rock and a hard
place
and didn't know how to get out of it
and only had you know
had very little to rely on but himself
even when you want to quit being a
filmmaker you can't
no and i've wanted to several times
the thing is to have such a discipline
that even when you want to quit
you're still working to give you an
example i will
my you know i'll get a rejection right
that i was expecting i was expecting to
get something whether it was in a film
festival or get into
some type of program or hear from the
showrunner about a possible directing
gig
and i just get the email that says no
right it doesn't matter how nice it is
it's a no
and you're just like ah how many of
these can i take that's it
i'm done i'm done and there i am writing
my next script there i am producing my
next thing it doesn't stop
you know what it means i've said that a
bunch of times and the wife always says
you know she's like you're telling me
you quit but
then you're the next breath you're
talking about the next thing you want to
shoot
the neck you know she's like i get it
she's like but you're not going to quit
so why do you tell yourself you're going
to quit
i go i just need 24 hours to get over my
rejection and then i'm back at it
but the point is to always be working
you know if you're just writing a
treatment if you're just writing a
short story if you're and here's the
thing i don't even
consider myself i consider myself more
of a director than a writer
but i'm probably the most disciplined as
a writer
you know because it's initial i can get
the story out
you know if i have a story to tell i
can't just get a pick up a crew
and the cast and go and tell that story
but i can't sit at my
typewriter or my my typewriter my laptop
and i can type it out and i can start to
see it and get excited about it
and do i know how i'm going to get it
made no but at least it's out and then i
have another one and then i have another
one so
being i'm probably the most disciplined
at writing because it's gonna hap it
happens every day it happens wherever
i'm
at i have a notebook or my laptop if i'm
working on my book or my pilot or my
script
my feature or my featurette where i'm
trying to finish my feature at
um that i'm producing and directing um
the discipline is it doesn't matter that
i tell myself i'm gonna quit um
my body and my mind are still working
i think it comes to how a marathon
runner
is just on automatic on those last three
to four miles
like they their body is telling them no
we're done but they still
find whatever that is to keep going
that's how i can equate playing the long
game and pursuing this
craft where do you find the ideas for
your stories
i would say a lot of my stuff is goes
into like kind of the complicated like
a mentor mentee relationship or the
brother relationship
brothers relationship those those
dynamics have always been a part of my
life
partly because i never had a big brother
and have a mentor so
i'm always investigating those things um
all the female characters in all of my
movies are all very
strong female characters before it
became a thing to put a strong female
character in
yeah because the muse comes from one and
that's my wife
so all of the charac all every female
character comes from her so they're
going to have those traits
um and so usually how
the story and i'm i'm an urban director
you know i'm in the urban genre i make
no apologies for that i love the urban
genre that's what i grew up watching as
a kid
it's what i still continue watching i
love gangster films
my stuff though comes from a place of
authenticity and genuineness
and also from an emotional place i
always say i go behind the headlines
so like for my first three films i
called them the drive-by chronicles
and i took them directly from a a
headline from a drive-by shooting
somewhere and then i created a story of
that because we don't get that
we get the headline but we don't know
how that family has reacted to that we
don't know how they're dealing with that
we don't know the repercussions in the
neighborhood of how they're dealing with
that
there are so many different aspects um
compelling story
telling and as a latino filmmaker i get
sometimes get [ __ ] for that but
my thing is if you haven't watched my
films you can't judge me just based on
the genre i choose to
tell my stories um if you've watched
them and you come across that
with that i'll even question you then
because i'm the writer
and i know it's going to be phony or
cliche or stereotypical
and the genre itself isn't it's how you
approach the characters
and i couldn't get the actors that i get
if my stuff was stereotypical because
they're not getting paid a ton of money
to be there
they're doing it because they responded
to the script
so that's where most of my stuff comes
from
i just love la i'm inspired by la and
where i live and the people that i've
been around
i'm inspired by the people that struggle
to
[Music]
just get up in the morning provide for
their family and
go to bed with some sense of
accomplishment for the day
or some uh fulfillment
with whatever it is that they're trying
to do uh
i know i'm more blue-collar that way i
consider myself a blue-collar filmmaker
because i didn't
go to film school i didn't learn
that way i didn't go to a fancy college
to learn writing a lot of uh
it's interesting there's a lot of show
runners now that are working on these
urban shows
are all they got writing straight out of
college i'm like how do you even know
this world
and for your average audience it's
enough but not for me
which might be why they're saying no to
having me direct
because they take a look at my reel and
they're like oh this guy's doing it for
real we don't want him around here
but uh um because that's been the kind
of the backlash i get but it also just
depends on
on a lot of times it's people's
perception
right and you can do nothing about that
i just can write
direct and tell the stories that i want
to tell in the way that i want to tell
them
and if people dig it then cool if they
don't
nothing i can do about that so sorry i'm
having trouble figuring out why would
they give you backlash if you
know a neighborhood or you want to delve
deeper into a headline
what would be the problem with that well
i'll put it this way
let's say you're
let's say you have a job as a mechanic
and you're a decent mechanic you know
enough about cars to be a mechanic
and you're put in charge of hiring
another mechanic are you going to hire a
mechanic who knows more than you
when they can only have two okay okay
does that make sense yeah it does you're
not going to hire that guy you don't
want that guy
in your garage he's going to take your
job right and that's probably wise
because i'm not a writer to be in a
writer's room i
see myself running a show i see myself
directing shows
um i see myself getting my own shows
done
so i think for now um with the nose i've
gotten from people
that's what my wife says you know and
and she's very
she doesn't feed my ego or anything
she's like
why are they gonna bring you're doing it
for real you got real people
you know i work with a lot of ex-gang
members she's like who are really good
actors it's not just having ex-gang
members to authenticate your work
can they act because i'm seeing a lot of
that now too i'm like
okay that's great he was just he spent
this many years in jail but he can't act
so but hollywood doesn't care they think
that well we got him and he has a great
story and we're going to sell that
that's what i'm seeing a lot of in tv
right now and i'm kind of like
there's such a lack of authenticity and
when you know there's a lack of
authentic authenticity is when they
constantly are saying how authentic the
show is
oh that was my next question what are
some of the red when you when you see
something and it's an
urban genre and then you go wait a
minute i can tell this is written by
someone
who lived on a cul-de-sac yeah
and had a swimming pool yeah so yeah
that's absolutely correct
um that was i think that's the red the
biggest red flag for me is when they
start talking about how authentic it is
or they start talking about they start
talking about everything except the
stories that they're trying to tell
because if it is you get engaged in the
storytelling
doesn't matter nothing else matters you
know and
particularly in my community like that's
all that's talked about now
you know i love ava duvornay she's
someone i look up to because she did a q
a recently
and she had on the director of a film
called [ __ ]
and she's like i'm not going to talk
about all the social and all the
being on an asian-american filmmaker
let's talk about the movie let's talk
about the craft of telling the story
and that's not that because you know
because you're a person of color
it's like you have to talk about some
type of issue when
i'm a filmmaker it doesn't mean i don't
have an opinion about things that are
happening in today's world
but they're gonna creep up in my films
and they're gonna creep up in
um genuine and in more subtle ways
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna promote my stuff
by a message uh just not gonna do that
i've seen filmmakers that first of all
doesn't work and
second of all it's a cheap way of
promoting yourself
let's say someone has a great story idea
what do they do next
well there's the thing is there's a lot
of things they can do um
if it's well if it's i get people that
come up to me with story ideas all the
time and i say well write it
you know they have an idea and they
think that's enough
and that's not enough if you have an
idea and you
manage to make it into a story and then
turn that story into a script
now you have something and then you say
well yeah that my script is so big it's
10 million dollar budget you know
there's nothing we can do about it
well what can you shoot from it that
isn't going to cost you 10 million
dollars
that's what i'm doing right now you know
a script i wrote been writing for 10
years that i want to get made
i finally just said i gotta shoot
something from this the script's done
it is done it's ready to go i'm not
gonna get money to do this
because they're not gonna understand it
unless i get some type of angel donor
no studio is gonna understand what i'm
trying to do here i'm not guard on
you know i'm not him they're not going
to take a chance on this
project but what can i do to help them
understand what it is
well there's three scenes i can shoot
that cost me very little money
and that's what i do so that's what i'm
doing right now there are no rules
like now is like the old west in terms
of independent filmmaking
is it harder to get something on the
theater absolutely
but to get something made it is not hard
to get it seen
and shown it's not hard now to get on
netflix that's going to be a little bit
harder
absolutely but it's not impossible you
know what i mean it's not a rich man's
game anymore
um you're only confined by
the things that you put in front of
yourself you know so i always tell
people like
shoot something from it or write
something smaller
you know don't i think your big idea is
going to be the first thing out i got a
friend right now that
it's gotta be 12 13 years and it's like
is it a great idea yeah it's the time
now yeah
but nobody's gonna trust you with a 40
million dollar budget
to do your pro your passion project
essentially
because they're going to ask what have
you been doing for 12 years
you've been having the same thing for 12
years
do something you should have been
building up to that
don't have one thing you know i don't
say
be a jack of all trades i'm saying as a
writer
have tears if you're a writer director
have tiers of things that you can do
if it's a three-page uh
short that's fine you could tell if you
could tell a story in beginning middle
and in three pages
that's a skill you know and now you have
something put it out there see what
people say about it
um it's it's always never relying on
this kind of like ethereal thing that
something is going to happen
it's always relying on your own two
hands
because then you have no expectations
right you can do it
and you people like it or don't like it
or find the right spot
you don't know there's so many you can
only control
what you what you can do not help not
everything else
you know i couldn't tell you how i was
gonna get my first three films financed
you know i didn't go about it uh the way
that normal people do
you know i took my short films and
packaged them like a dvd you would buy
in a you know at a video store
and i passed them out to all the local
film festivals that rejected those films
and guess what there was a distributor
producer there and he ended up
financing my first three films oh wow so
that's a cool story
you just have to find new ways you know
i'm not a big proponent of crowdfunding
um but if
you know my thing is go get a go get a
job for three months and
save up you know why don't ask people to
give you money for something that you
don't even know if you're capable of
pulling off
and you you've said earlier that you
feel like the first film
that an indie filmmaker makes whether
it's through crowdfunding
a combination family friends co-workers
that's easy
yes and then subsequent ones
very very tough very tough why is that
well let it
if it's a double-edged sword so let's
say you've
crowdfunded your first film right you
got it you're 22 000. 22 000 seems to be
the the magic number that everyone goes
after right
so you crowdfund you do it and everyone
comes to the screening and they're all
excited and they got their button
and their t-shirt or whatever and then
nothing happens
okay nothing in the sense of it didn't
go to sundance or didn't get
distribution or
it didn't do anything so you start your
next one right
now you have to make your second film
that a lot of people gonna be like well
i gave you a hundred dollars last time
to support you i don't have that money
to help you with this second one you're
gonna have to figure that out
you know or you know that
that becomes then it becomes about the
crowdfunding not about the storytelling
you know because the amount of work it
takes just to crowdfund
is unbelievable and it's not something i
enjoy at
all you know and to me it's like if you
have 22
000 that's what you're raising you a
percentage of that's gonna go to
um is going to go to the the
the the the platform that you're using
plus
a percentage of that's going to go to
all the little things that you've
promised people whether they're buttons
or coffee mugs or whatever
and then a lot of people notice you have
to pay a tax on that because it's
considered income
unless you're a non-profit but if you're
making a movie you want to make a profit
so then what do you have left over you
know and then if let's say
you owe your rent the next month i've
seen that happen too many times there
was a two-year
period where me and my wife were
donating hundred dollars to
uh projects that were being crowdfunded
and we did 20
in a two-year period so it's about 2 000
over two years
out of those 20 projects one of them was
made
you know so i just stopped and i get
people all the time hey can you help us
out can you help us out i said look man
i wish you well be at your screening
i'll share whatever you wanted me to
share but
i'm not i'm not giving money anymore i
got two kids and a wife and
i want to put them both through my two
kids through college
you know so i go what i wish you well
you know and then
for sure enough that like you know you
hear it every day on social media
then as soon as the money is raised you
don't hear about the project anymore i'm
like what happened to your project
well rents do that's the problem
with this script that you'd been writing
for 10 years or maybe would you
write it for 10 years sorry or did it
take 10 years for you to get to this
point wow it took 10 years for me to get
to this point
okay it took me about three or four
years to write it
and it's my 10th script yeah my 10th
screenplay
and so when you said i'm gonna just do
three scenes
is that it yeah i'm shooting three
scenes that show the character
from the womb to a 10 year old to an 18
year old
ah so you're doing it in in sequential
order then oh okay
okay that's was what i was wondering is
how are you determining which scenes to
shoot so you're i'm showing
his journey in little increments and i'm
hoping the audience
is going to go wow what happened between
here and here what happened between here
and there
because in between those scenes i have
an incredible actor
uh chicano icon actor that i've grown up
watching pepe cerna
and he plays what i'm calling the
chicano chorus and he's
it's uh it's i wrote it in iambic
pentameter
so he's telling this shakespearean story
in between
those vignettes to fill the audience in
the blank
this is very stylized
[Music]
and i'm very happy with it i have one
one of the vignettes left to shoot but
um
i'm editing it and i'm rewriting that
last vignette
uh because i've been completely happy of
it and they're not taken from the script
the story is but the scripts are the
script
only one scene is actually word for word
from the script
i had to modify the other ones to show
some history and a little bit of
that character's journey how do you know
you have a great protagonist
i don't i don't ever yeah
don't ever um
it's a chance you know with first
writing it and then bringing the right
actor
you know that was something that a lot
of actors take for granted is can they
carry a movie
you know in an independent world like
there are no you know you're looking for
someone you have to go off your instinct
is this guy going to carry this movie
you know and
are people going to be interested in
this person through
out the entire hour and a half that's
something i don't take for i don't take
that for granted
you know because if they don't the
movie's done
you know and i've been fortunate that
i've worked with actors that have
moved on to bigger and better things and
that's been a validation of for me
because when i cast them they weren't
sag they didn't have an agent they
didn't
they were diamonds in the rough um so
i'm always
my wife says you're every actor's good
luck charm she's like they always move
on to bigger and better things well
that's great
but uh but it's so it's a validation of
my casting process as well
where do you find your actors it'll be a
variety of things um
actors access breakthrough services um
i've done enough now where i'll ask
other actors to refer
actors and that's been a really great
thing because
then it because not every actor can play
the part right i'll give you an example
of where that happened and counter punch
was my fifth film we're casting a
grandmother and i brought in an actor to
be
the uncle and he says you know i got a
great actress that i worked with in new
york who would be great
as the grandmother and i go who is who
is she ivan cole
and i'm like i'm not familiar with her
he's like she's she's up
she's been in the business a long time
but she's uh she's going to be booking
something very quickly i mean very big
soon she's like but he's like but i
think she'd be great
she was the first one i ended up casting
in that film and we brought her in and
we read
like almost a full year when we
initially had the initial funding
she came in for that table read she was
that character and then
uh when that funding fell through we had
the initial the
the second reading for that um and she
stayed with the project the entire time
she's on jane the virgin which just
ended a five year run
and um just amazing amazing woman
amazing actress but
there was someone i got from another
actor you know it was yvonne cole
and um yeah so it's a it's a combination
it's a combination of things um
sometimes i see a play
or if i s just watching tv just paying
attention
you know like i've always said that the
way for us to get through
writers or directors and actors is to
supersede the process
you know what i mean if if a show is
relying on casting directors well who
they're going to bring in
right they have their own people they're
going to bring in and maybe they
to weed out everybody there are all
these systems to weed out people
but you may be waiting out a diamond in
there
and my attitude is like i want to see
everybody
you know and i is that time consuming
yes
but that's how i found my actors
so you've written scripts for film and
now you'd like to add television
i'm looking to direct get into directing
television directing okay yeah
i really would like to i mean i have a
pilot that i've written that i would
like to get made it's about the la riots
it's an
honest portrayal of the la riots in los
angeles so it'd be very difficult to get
done
but uh but in the meantime my my focus
over the last three years has been
television
um just after you've done seven feature
films
i love it and i still would do it um but
i i
really i
i just there's so many things i've been
more inspired by television right now
that's than
what's happening in cinema so that's
where my
focus has been you know and plus it's
like that thing too
where when i was first starting out you
know i shot my first feature on an xl1
a canon xl1 nobody was doing that at
that time
so i felt like okay cool you're putting
yourself in a class
right where you're not doing what
everyone else is doing
and then after i made my first feature
i was like well no one's done a second
so my thing was do a second so my thing
was always
to put myself in a category where i
didn't have any peers
and so now i'm in a place where
everybody i know is making a movie
because they can that's a bad place for
me to be so
i don't know a lot of people that are
getting into directing television
because it's very difficult
and even with the diversity talk that
again like i talked about earlier that's
on the surface
but underneath there's not much changing
so that's what i'm finding because i
don't have an agent i'm reaching out
directly to showrunners
and i'm reaching out for shows that i'm
right for and the good thing on that
is i get people that will reach back
they may say no right now they're saying
keep in touch with i love your reel keep
in touch i can't believe you don't have
an agent i can't believe you're not
directing tv
already i can't help you right now but
keep in touch
you know that's a win that's a win if i
get a showrunner
showrunner if i reach out to a
showrunner on social media and they send
me back their email
that's a win even if i don't get the job
because maybe i'll get the job next year
we'll see we'll see we do an interview
again and i'm
directing some television let me put
that back let me do that again
maybe we're here next year and i'm
directing television
who knows do you still submit to film
festivals i don't
no i over the years i've realized that
all the film festivals i ever screened
at were always through an invitation
or through someone i know i can't tell
you that
in the thousands of dollars i've spent
submitting to film festivals that there
was
one that i got into a direct submission
just a blind submission
i can't tell you that there's one they
were always through people i knew
filmmakers i knew hey send your movie
over to this guy they need
your type of movie um and i just don't
feel
there's so much content now like i just
don't feel those are the places that
people are looking anymore even sundance
maybe more so but
that will always be a major film
festival but
um what i've you know after counter
punch
had gotten into netflix got distribution
through lionsgate and then was on
netflix for two years
there were films that went to sundance
the year that counterpunch would have
screened because i did submit that film
and they were on sundance for six months
so
i i stopped looking at it that way i
like i want my movies to be seen i don't
care about awards
is that a bucket list thing for as a
filmmaker absolutely
i will say this though about sundance
i've submitted three of my seven there
and um i would occasionally
go to an event not sundance event just a
film event and a programmer would come
up to me hey i saw
i saw la guapa man i pushed it forward
i'm a sundance programmer i saw counter
punch man i loved it i
pushed it forward it made me feel good
just to know that
the films i did submit to sundance did
get seen
and even though they got passed on i
think a lot of people are like are they
even watching all these films
i can tell you that they are because i
don't know who the programmers are
it you have to they have to come and
introduce themselves to me and say
i saw your film and i loved it and i
pushed it forward i'm sorry i didn't get
in
um that's enough for me i'm like cool
i'm just glad someone watched it over
there
um but no i i don't i think
film festivals now are just for ego
again i i'm not interested i'm not
interested in that if someone genuinely
likes my
film and wants to show it absolutely um
and i have a couple of favorites
um and i'll be surprised like i got
invited to the chicanendi film festival
in denver colorado i didn't know they
were even paying attention to my stuff
and
they said hey we see you made all these
films or chicano film festival you want
to they flew me out they were so
nice to me and and that was cool it was
unexpected you know
um but and then other film festivals you
go to and you just feel like
i don't know it's like the films are
secondary you know it's it's about
the event or there's one movie that's
really big and we're all like the kind
of satellites around this
giant moon of a film and um
they all get lost but i've never had a
screening at a film festival
that was bigger than screenings i put on
myself
and so people that you've grown up with
that you know
have come to see your films have you
screened them in wilmington or around
that area
no well i did do a screening in the
south bay at the rolling hills 20
for my sixth film uh called it's has two
titles there's a spanish language tower
laguapa and then there's thou shalt not
kill
and i did that one there and that was
cool because that was a film that was a
movie theater i used to go to as a kid
and sneak into and see r-rated movies at
so the screen there was pretty cool
um and there were some people that were
there from when i'd grown up
people that were paying attention i
didn't know we're paying attention so
that was the only time i would love to
scream in wilmington but we never we
don't have a oh and i did
at the warner grand in san pedro i
screened there and i used to see movies
there as well so that was
those were pretty cool but they were
very small screenings you know
like in warner grand is this giant art
deco theater and i think there were
maybe 50 people there
um but when i did my initial
counterpunch screening we did two
screenings in one night and 150 people
you know each screening so the film
festival does their best to try to
promote everybody but it's really
essentially up to you
you know and i just find it easier that
if i'm having the screening it's easy
for me to promote it myself and rally
people to go see it as opposed to going
to a film festival screening i don't
know why because they use their
website sometimes it's confusing they
gotta find the film or find the link or
you know whatever it is but
but uh i don't yeah i don't i don't
waste my time
collecting laurels on my posters i just
don't
do you have tips on writing dialogue
where it doesn't sound forced
or even omitting dialogue i think the
only way to do that
is to watch movies and read scripts with
good dialogue
[Music]
have good conversations
that's a tough one i don't know you just
know when it's not
right uh for me like
some of the masters like a tarantino
like
they approach it like a novel i think
more like a book
i think a lot of it has to do with
what's not said
um if you if you have clear if you have
a clear
understanding of the relationships
between the characters the dialogue
comes off more naturally
in between those two so i think you have
to start there
you know if you know your characters
they start to talk to each other on
their own in a weird way
uh that's never been an issue for me
like my issue is i write too much
dialogue like my first film was like
they just said look man this is a
10-page scene and they're just talking
and i'm like well i don't know how to
cut it because i love everything they're
saying and i'm like
that's what they say he's like well we
can cut it now we cut it in the editing
room and i thought well let's just do
that we can cut it in the editing room
if it's
not working but um it was a challenge
you know for my actors to do a six-page
scene
you know in six pages of dialogue
because i'm someone that likes to keep
the camera on them
and have them go through it i'm not
gonna break it up i want them to be
emotionally connected
and my stuff has a rhythm to it so if
they're not on that
that train they're gonna have a hard
time
you know but uh my dialogue is what
attracted a lot of actors to it i just
they always you know whenever i hear an
actor say
um when they come when they say the
writing's so good they didn't have to
work as hard
that means they didn't have to sell it
they just had to speak it
you know if you ever read titanic the
scripted titanic
is really bad it's like if you read it
and that was the only thing that didn't
get nominated for an academy award
ironically was the script but when you
read it
i mean the story is there and the
relationships are there i'm just talking
about the dialogue
but leonardo dicaprio and kate winslet
are so skilled that when they say the
lines
you just believe it you know i'm sorry i
just
i don't think i'm the only one that said
that about titanic's script
um and i'm not talking story structure
i'm not talking about anything i'm just
talking about the dialogue of that
you know um but if you have good enough
actors it doesn't matter like
they can sell it that's what they get
paid for right but um
whenever i hear an actor say yeah i
didn't have to work as hard on this one
that means that
it was right there you know and with my
dialogue they have to pick it up fast
because
i'm shooting a feature in three weeks
you know so
you have a maximum of five takes
you know yeah is that what you meant by
a rhythm
because yeah okay yeah and um
you know if i have to camp i have more
than one camera and a couple occasions i
did then it's great
then then i have this thing going back
in this tennis match going back and
forth between the characters but
um in terms of tips that's a tough one i
think just know who
know who your characters are before you
start your screenplay
and it's weird but they start talking to
each other
it's very strange but that's that's been
my experience
it's like wait a minute how the hell
like and i'm shocked by it every time i
write a script
so that's the first thing's like oh my
god how am i going to do this and then
you just start
getting into a flow and it just takes
practice right the more you do it
the better you're going to get at it you
know but don't give away plot in your
dialogue
we don't you know we don't talk like
that right
we don't talk about plot in life you
know
so you shouldn't you sh that should be a
first sign that the dialogue's bad
have you had actors on set and you
realize that it's way more effective for
them to say nothing
and you decide in the moment to take it
out yeah oh absolutely because i've i
come from silent movies i also did a
short film series
uh called the misadventures of trollo
chaplin and they were silent short films
black and white silent short films where
there was no dialogue
and in my seventh feature film there was
very little dialogue it was all the
actor
so there was a lot of that's sort of my
background is now
to give less and tell more between the
characters
through action and emotion and less
through dialogue
that's more my just that's kind of where
i'm leaning right now
um and not be so in love with my words
that well can we show that
without them saying anything or saying a
lot lot less
yes always cut the fat like cut as much
as you can
you know the the simpler it is the
the the fuller it can be in a weird way
do you see that from being a beginning
filmmaker all the way until now
that really a lot of it was about
cutting the fat in someone in some sense
yes because my process started you know
when i first
wrote my first screenplay that it was i
didn't have notes or anything i just had
an idea
right and so i would just start and then
at the end of that process you just have
this like
really fatty piece of meat
and then you realize i don't need this i
don't need that i don't need this or you
repeat yourself
you know now i'm i'm a more disciplined
a writer in a sense i'll write a
treatment first
so i don't have as much fat once my
script is done
because i already know what i'm not
going to use
because i've already done notes i've
done a treatment for it and now i'm
going to script form
and that's only been like the last two
or three scripts that i've written
you know so um i'm constantly learning
because i didn't start from some place
of filmmaking you know
when you're starting a story are you
starting with an outline i didn't always
do that i actually learned how to do
that recently i
one of the best creative decisions i've
ever made was joining a writing group
i was in a bubble for a very long time
but it's also
hard to find a writing group where
everyone knows how to give notes
and knows how to take notes and so i've
been
i was very lucky because what we have is
very unique and the people within that
writing group understand that too and
i've gotten jobs out of this writing
group you know we're all kind of looking
out for each other there's only eight of
us
but um i you know i was a type i would
just turn in pages and say okay this is
what mine they're like well we don't
know where the story is going can you
just outline it for us and i'm like
no i don't outline just follow this give
me the notes on the pages like yeah well
we can't give you notes we don't know
where the story
is going and so then i had to think
about
how do i do that and i i started writing
um learning how to write treatment you
know and and that was great
first practice in terms of just writing
a treatment makes it very easy
for you to pitch your script um so
there's that skill
and then outlining it you know when i
would get lost normally when i'm writing
a script right i'm just going and i get
to a point i don't know where the story
is going to go from there
that's normally how i would write i'm
not saying it's the right way to do it
but that's how i would do it and then i
would
something would strike me or i would
know okay well over here i know this is
going to happen so let me just start
there
so these huge gaps in my scripts and
then i would connect those gaps
well now i outline my entire script my
entire story
first i'll take those from notes so i'll
have a notebook with me everywhere i go
so it doesn't matter where i'm at an
idea will come and i'll write it down
and um i'm starting to get into
recording but i'm very old school so i
start
just writing down and a page of notes
in my little notebook will be about 10
pages of
script so i'll usually then on my
writing day
will translate that to those 10 pages
um but now that was the old way now i
will outline everything
so i'll outline the entire stories and
i'm able to write my scripts a lot
faster
because of that because i already know
the story is going to go the dialogue
the characters are fleshed out
and the dialogue will comes a lot easier
and a lot faster
so i definitely recommend that but you
have to learn how to outline you have to
learn how to write a treatment
you have to learn how to com convert
your notes
to those things me i just started
writing scripts
because that's what i i i understood the
script right
and started writing there but that was a
very stop start kind of kind of way i
like to now just like a fluid
like like playing a piano you know once
the outline is done
and i start the screenplay it's like
playing the piano for me
what did the writing group teach you
about um giving notes
not to give notes in the sense that this
is how i would do it
you're giving notes in terms of what's
missing what's not being communicated
what do you is this your intention here
because this is what i'm getting from it
um you're never coming from a place of
ego either
um and sometimes that happens sometimes
you get hurt by the notes or you feel
like sometimes someone gives a bad note
you know that happens too but with this
particular group we've established
ourselves enough where we
we do hurt each other on occasion but we
can recover
you know and move on you know just
recently
like i'm doing this screenplay and
they're like all of them were in
agreement like
kill the first activist like it's you
don't need it
and that was like i was just so against
that
like i'm like no i'm not killing that
act
and then i turned in the outline and so
when i started the script you know i
said i appreciate all your guys's notes
but
i didn't take that one and so the first
10 pages are
this act you told me to kill and then
two-thirds of them were like oh
okay i get it because sometimes it's not
always on the outline either
sometimes it's in the screenplay you
know and they were judging the outline
they're like okay now i see
i see what you're saying now because
when i send the script they're like
yeah this is engaging i'm gonna treat i
totally get it now but that was also me
sticking to my gut
but normally when everybody in the room
is against something
that's when i know that that it's
special
francis ford coppola said the things
that they want to fire you for when
you're a young filmmaker are the things
that they give you awards for when you
when you're older and that's in the back
of my mind so when they all when they
were all in agreement
if they were like half liked it half
didn't like it i would have
been more conflicted about whether or
not to keep it
but when all of them were like no this
you don't need that i'm like
no this we're going forward with this
i'm trusting my gut
you guys are wrong on this one and i i
proved some of them wrong
uh on that on that next when i
presented the script what is this
writing group taught you about outlining
it's like a combination of being concise
and being as detailed as
you possibly can um sometimes i don't
have the patience for that because i
know
i'm going for a feeling right so i'll
start writing out a scene
that doesn't necessarily feed the
outline that's going to be in the script
so i just need to say on a beach
somewhere
whatever the two characters have a
conversation
so i some of them are very good and very
detail-oriented with their outlines and
will continue to do that until they get
to the script
me since i'm the director like there's
only three directors in our group
they're director writers
so for the writers in the group their
outlines are going to be far more
detailed
and i have to remind them sometimes i'm
a director no one's going to direct this
script except me
so i don't need to write all that out
for myself and i don't necessarily need
to write all that out
for an investor i need the store i need
them to get the
gift the gist of the story and then
hopefully that's enough i need them to
be
interested enough to to read the
screenplay
um so i could be i i would be more
detailed for things i'm not going to
shoot
that maybe but most of the things that i
write i know i'm going to shoot them
so i don't necessarily have to be that
for the group to know where i'm going
and who the characters are what the log
line is how what the pitch is
that's what i present and then all of
the great nuances that i want to put
into it go into the screenplay
so if someone said i love what you've
written and i hate to use the a word
they say it's authentic
[Laughter]
but are you willing to to then
turn it over to them and and not be the
director what if they say
sorry we've already kind of like filled
some roles here but we love the script
we love the story the voice
is original right i don't i don't know
i've never been in that situation
um it depends on how attached i am to
the script but
every screenplay i've ever written i've
had a personal attachment to i've never
not written anything that wasn't
personal
or i had an attachment to it i've never
written something just for fun
or just because i thought it would this
would be cool like
everything that i've written has been
personal everything
so i don't see myself
that's why i don't think i could ever be
in a writer's room you know i just don't
know how to
i don't know that i wouldn't want to put
myself into someone else's characters on
a daily basis
i think that you those are work that
that's a that's work
um and i'm sure it's great work uh
but that's not necessarily for me i need
to dictate the story
and i need to dictate the characters do
you think it's because they mean so much
to
these characters that you're not you're
not just writing just like this
this this character they mean a lot to
you yeah they don't
if if i'm spending time with them then
i'm it's not that they mean so much they
do mean something it's i'm protective of
them
and i'm selfish with them
but in a good no no no it sounds like
because you're protective yeah
no absolutely yeah absolutely and
i'm invested with the actor because
they're they're communicating that
character
you know and they're then now they're
invested in it now they're
they're going to protect this story
they're going to protect the character
you know um and that's exciting that's
when i share
that's what i share is when we're on day
one is set
now i start sharing you know the story
and the screenplay and the characters
with everybody
and hopefully the audience
responds
right so it's almost they're like real
people and you're
like you don't want to let them go yeah
absolutely i definitely look them that
way
absolutely did you ever feel there were
limitations
with using one of the most expensive
cameras you've used for your sets where
when you use something that might have
been cheaper you felt like
you focused more on the storytelling
what do you mean
well you know how people always use well
i i don't have access to this budget so
i can't get this camera
so i can't do the film but then
sometimes
that actually makes you comfortable a
better story yeah absolutely like i
my last film that i shot and when i tell
people i'm like
again i'm not a film student but i know
that it's the lenses it's not
necessarily the camera it's the lenses
you choose
you know so you know i've shot on reds
three of my films were shot in a red
i knew for marigold i wasn't going to
shoot on a red but that
kind of helped us because we shot on a
dslr
now i shot on dslr but i shot it with
zeiss prime lenses
so that gave us access to a whole the
whole city you know i did have a permit
because i
was gonna shoot in the la river and i
wasn't going
you know had a makeup artist i had all
kinds that i was not going to risk
us being kicked out of l.a river um so i
did get a permit for that but we went to
um
grand union station we had a camera we
shot on a train
you know you could do so much more with
a dslr but
and i love the way that film looked
because of the lenses we chose and just
the way the days panned out it was very
color i wanted to be very colorful and
we always seem to get a day
we were always shooting after a rain you
know so there was like the clouds and
the sky was super blue and the air was
clear
and but shooting that particular film
gave me mobility
and flexibility because one of my
characters was schizophrenic
and he had no dialogue i didn't know
what he was going to do
so i would just give him a scenario and
say this is what i need to end up
happening
and then i would be right there with my
dp and he's shooting it
and then you know he had to be very
skilled because he says keep things in
focus and
and and composed um because i wanted the
shot to be interesting and then
if something got messed up it was just a
simple thing of okay do that again
ivan but do it this way and stay in this
stay right here don't move out so we can
keep you in focus okay
and then we shoot so it's just such a
very great fluid way of shooting
um that particular film and it was fun
it was fun to shoot because we just go
go and
we were just using natural light
everywhere um
and that could be a hit or miss if you
don't have a good dp if you don't have a
good colorist which have an amazing
colorist
um i knew that was going to look great
with what with
once we had all the pieces put together
um
so that was definitely one of those
instances you know it's not
the camera it's who's behind the camera
uh
that's the biggest lesson but you know
people want you know
i i during that process i got i kind of
got it because
it didn't feel like i was making a movie
you know i wanted the big camera and the
lights and everything and
it's a crew of five and i'm over my dp's
shoulder
you know giving him direction but then
when i looked at the images
and the footage it was big and it was
alive
and it was emotional so it just doesn't
matter
all the other stuff right that's for
your ego
and at the during the time of that
process when i was kind of asking myself
you know
wow this is really a movie now or not
and
there's a great shot i saw and it's of
uh
chivo with uh alejandro enyodatu
and they're in the forest you know for
revenant and there's chivo with a camera
digital camera this big
and leonardo dicaprio's right there and
alejandro is over his shoulder and this
is almost the exact same thing
as my you know that picture i just
painted of me over my
dps and that's not just real of course
they have a ton of more money and every
resource and everything else but
that's essentially what it is you know
and if your story is strong enough
it really will it goes beyond the
technology and that's the
best advice i could give to any
filmmaker is it don't get wrapped up in
that
if you have a strong story and you're
able to execute that story
it'll go beyond the technology you know
because essentially the audience doesn't
care what you shot on
they don't care you know is it your
movie for cinephiles is it for
for me it's for the person who wants
an escape who worked a hard day and
wants an escape or they want
to feel something they want some truth
um yeah i mean that's that's what
propels me
do you think about the flaw in your
protagonist while you're writing the
story
no if i'm writing them they already have
flaws
no i don't think about that i just try
to make if i make them human they
already have them
i don't try to accentuate i don't try to
manipulate i don't try to impose a flaw
um if i'm making a human character they
already have flaws
that's what makes them genuine that's
what makes them authentic
i don't need to add a flaw to them if
i'm adding a flaw to them then
i think that's why the superman
character is such a hard character
to grasp because
he's so good and he's invulnerable
that's not interesting you know what i
mean he can fly which is cool
but how do you make that character
vulnerable how do you make him
have flaws you know he has to be a bad
guy and he's never going to be a bad guy
he's superman
he has to have some some type of
that's a lot of weight on somebody to
have that right
i don't know if that's been explored but
i don't know that you can explore that
with that character
i don't think the audience would accept
it you know
so um in terms of creating flaws for my
characters
they already have them yeah it's
interesting because we want to see
actors on screen portray that but then
we want to believe
that these public figures don't have
flaws
yeah it becomes a hero worship you know
the people that we believe in
it becomes a hero worship that's where
like you know that's where like
celebrity or let's say famous people
it's like i'm just like you yeah
that's a true statement i am just like
you it's it's what we put on them
because they're
on a big screen or they're in tv or
politics or whatever
it's what we it's our perception of them
that's why i don't get star struck
because i'm not
i i judge a person by what's right in
front of me i don't go by the facade and
everything else
um so i don't get starstruck the only
time i did get star trek was when i got
to meet my hero muhammad ali
but that's muhammad ali you know so
that's
and he is flawless and for in my opinion
he's a legend i meant a legend a living
legend
so um he's the only one but i don't i
don't get starstruck other than that
you know i just don't did you say
anything to him
yes i did i got to uh i got to tell him
what he meant to me
my entire life and how he inspired me to
to sometimes say things and do things
that not everybody's going to like
but if it's your truth that you have to
that you have to say it and you have to
do it
not everyone's going a lot of people
don't realize muhammad ali was not liked
for
the very beginning of his career he was
not liked i mean
it's hard for people to imagine that but
i know the man's story and
um yeah he he had it very hard
and to keep his poison and
everything that he did that's why i just
don't care what people think
what did he say when you said that i
can't tell you that okay all right
all right we have to read it in the book
no i don't even put that in but
that's safe for me okay but that shows
that that meant a lot to you
oh yeah you're not you're not about like
a cheap story yeah tell everyone
i i shared it with my wife but i never i
tell people that story of how i got to
meet them and the whole
the whole night and everything and um uh
but i don't tell them everything that's
fair okay
i know we touched on some of this
previously i'm wondering if you could
just go back to
the hardest year for you as a filmmaker
and why and then the easiest year for
you
as a filmmaker and what was your
what was the outcome of your thought
after experiencing both years
wow um those were back to back
the worst year and my best year
were back to back and some i mean try to
give you the cliff notes
but like 2010 like i mentioned earlier
started with my son
getting in an accident i was getting
ready to get ready to shoot my third
film
and you know on the day after his
accident basically
i literally had sent my script to my
producer that morning
the morning my son was in his was
injured so
my assistant director was already
scheduling things and and and
getting things you know starting our
prep
and i was supposed to shoot that in
february so
you know they were calling me she was
calling me and people were calling me i
wasn't answering my phone obviously my
son was my number one priority
and when i got on like where the hell
are you we got the script
we have questions about this that and
the other and i called them i said
my son was in an accident um he's in icu
and i i don't i i just don't have any
answers for you
you have my script you paid me for it if
you want if you guys got to stay with
that schedule just
do whatever you want with it get another
director i don't care
and my producer at the time was
knew my family so he was just like don't
worry about anything
we're ready when you are and they had
you know they had a deal with
blockbuster so they had to get movies
out at certain times
he's like we'll we'll figure it out he
said just don't worry about the movie
take care of your family
and just you know keep us posted on how
julian's doing
and that just made me feel good from a
producer to saving that because i
wouldn't
i wouldn't have faulted them if he just
said you know what we're going to hire
another director because we have a
schedule
but you know of course you know stay
with your son
so it wasn't until like three weeks
after that
accident and he got home that my wife
said go make your movie he's fine and i
said
i didn't want to go anywhere really i
just wanted to be with my son she's like
you
you love this script you put your heart
into he's fine he's totally fine you
know and
go make your movie so i
called my producer i said let's let's
just started on
pre-production he's like we're already
there i said
i go did you hire director he's like
nope we knew we know you're coming back
i said all right so i went and shot my
third
film and i edited in mexico city
uh when i got back i got told that
and this is the bad year so i got told
uh by an actor i was working with that
he's got his life story
uh produced he's a bipolar golden gloves
boxer who was an actor and he got
the money from this these two brothers
that wanted to produce his film
and and then when i had gotten back from
mexico i was told by my producer we have
the money to do your
your fourth so i was like great what's
there i'll get started
so i started not bartending as much
because i was working
so heavily on two scripts at the same
time which i don't necessarily suggest
but they were
what was great about that is when i
would submit an idea for one of the
scripts and it would come back from the
producers they didn't like the scene i
would take that scene and put it for my
other script
so i was able to take mix and match them
a little bit
um that was a great time but then at the
end of that process
like i was ready i was like okay good
let's go i was wanting to quit my job i
wanted
the financing for both these to go
through and then it was there was some
skepticism and then blockbuster went out
of business and that just
killed the fourth the budget for the
fourth film so i was like okay i still
have counterpunch
and then those two punks there were
producers decided that they were going
to use my connections to do
their thing and they didn't want to
produce our thing anymore they were
going to do their own thing and they
ended up doing some
stereotypical really crappy horror
thing that they did so i was just like
left holding this bag and i'm like
and i'm like two months behind on on our
mortgage and i'm like
i've got to get back to work so
i just threw those both you know in a
bin and i was at work and i was just
like picking up shifts left and right i
was working
five six shifts a week and i just was
not making
enough money because it was the economy
turn around at that time
and i'm just couldn't catch up i
couldn't catch up man
and i just by the time
december rolled around i was ready to
premiere my third
my third feature film and it was very
ironic because it was at rally studios
and it was
probably the week before that
it's very it's very strange when you're
doing your dream
but your your life is kind of
going south right but this is going it
was
you're it's this weird tug of war
and i just remember after telling my
wife look i
[ __ ] up we're losing the house we're
going to have to move
i don't know how aggressive they are
going to be at coming to take the house
my biggest fear was coming home and
there being a lock and picking up my
kids and there being a lock on our front
door we can't get into our house
i go so we're gonna have to move uh
right after this shoot right after this
the screening and she was so gracious
about it
um and i remember sitting outside
going i'm screening my third feature
film next week
and i'm losing my house how did i even
[ __ ] get here
and i remember going to raleigh studios
to test
out i was basically at that point
thinking i'm gonna stop
after the third one i'm gonna stop i've
given up so much and sacrificed so much
after this third one i'm done and i
remember going to rally studios
and i was gonna do a test of my hard
drive because the movie was on the hard
drive
and the projectionist was there and you
know these guys
they do this this is their job they've
seen a million filmmakers come in and
they could care less he just wants to
get in and out we're gonna do we're
gonna do a test i'm gonna go 10 every 10
minutes to see if it's okay
i'm like okay cool i go i just have a
concern about the first
10 uh minutes here and then we'll jump
and he's like all right
um so go ahead and sit down you can call
me so i'm sitting in this rally
studio screening watching my movie up
there and i'm like this
first time i've seen on the big screen
i've edited a million times on a small
screen
but oh it was just so big and the nuance
and
the performances and it was there and
i'm just like watching it going wow
i'm like watching it for the first time
by myself in raleigh studios
and before i knew it i'm like two-thirds
the way through
and i haven't heard from the
projectionist and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
only have like a half hour to really
be there i only have a half hour time to
test my movie so i turn around and he's
like
four rows behind me watching the movie
and i and i go like this to him and he's
like
don't worry about it don't worry about
it he starts he's watching my movie he
got into my movie
and i just was like it was just a great
moment in
such a dark time for me and i remember
going to him going and we watched the
whole thing
so me and him watch little things like
man i loved it loved it because i see so
much crap come in here man
with he's what was your budget on that
and i told him and he's like no way
no way he's all i'm gonna keep my eye on
you and i go thanks so much matt
and um and then you know we had the
screening it was a great screening and
it got distribution
and um but again it wasn't enough money
by that time i had i was already gotten
another apartment we were moving out
so 2010 ended with us losing our house
um and moving and you know having
movies out i was still doing shorts i
was still writing i was still doing all
those things
so then when we moved out i was pretty
much
done with filmmaking i basically said
this is too much of a sacrifice
that i put on my family if it was just
me who cares right but
yeah that was tough conversation with my
wife and kids
and 2010 sorry 2010 2010 okay
so we get the 2011 and it wasn't dire we
weren't homeless you know we i
i had three um
it was actually a really good lesson in
negotiation particularly if i come
against producers or
or distributors again but i had three
real estate agents that were like
hawks like rats trying to get our house
and so i basically i emailed them
individually saying
i have five other real estate agents
that are offering me this amount of
money to move out in three weeks
whichever one of you comes with the
um with the highest number is the one
that's going to get this house because i
had to sign off on
on giving it to them and so i got a good
chunk of money
to have a little bit of a nest day even
though i was broke my credit was shot
everything was shot
get us into a nice apartment and then
start over sorry just real quick how did
they know that they must have checked
the bank record oh yeah okay it's a
whole racket man
it's a whole racket the banks were never
going to
never no intention of helping people
keep stay in their homes because it
would have been very easy to do um
so i i was like january
february of 2011 now and
i'm done i'm done uh my family's safe
we're in a nice place i'm on a balcony
i'm reading a book my producer calls i'm
like
oh what does he want hey what's up hey
man
fourth feature is on we got some money
we're gonna go forward
i go no no i'm not doing it and he's
like what do you mean you're not doing
it he's like we love your script we're
going to go forward and shoot mexico
i said no no i'm not doing it
he's like well i go what's the budget
and the budget was just ridiculously low
i go my film can't be shot for that he's
like we'll make it happen man he
they were looking out for their company
um
they wanted to stay relevant i go let me
write something else that's smaller
no we can make we can do it we can do it
and i said
all right um all right let's do it and
so
then it was just hard to cast because
the budget was so low but i
felt like okay here's my second shot
right i didn't have to worry about money
at this point we had money in the bank
we were safe i'm gonna go make another
movie i thought my career was done
that was a bad motivation to go make
that movie
because i pulled in some really great
cast and i just didn't do
right by them in that film even though i
loved the process of it
it was still compromising too much for
the budget
but we did it and at the end of that
i was in mexico on our last two nights
of shooting
and the producer for the counterpunch
project calls me
says where are you i said in mexico he's
like i got the funding for counterpunch
now
you need to come and interview with
these producers because they're
interviewing directors from caa
and william morris and you know all the
big agencies and i'm like no that's my
movie man i wrote it they're like
they're going to pay you for the script
but they don't want you to direct it
well that's [ __ ]
and he says well when can you get here i
go i rap in two days i'll be there in
two days
and um i go set up a meeting for monday
i get back on sunday he's like okay
so i tell my editor who was with me on
set at the time
because he was cutting the movie as i
was shooting that was my normal process
i loved to do that haven't had the
luxury of doing that so i said um i told
my editor okay stop what you're doing
he's like what i go
stop editing i need you to cut me a
trailer he's like why i go because
our next gig is going to be based on how
good that trailer is
he's all serious i said yeah you're
coming with me on that one i go but i
need you to cut it and you
have 24 hours he's like okay so he's
like
cutting the trailer and he's not working
on the movie so my producer on that film
is telling me
why isn't the editor working on the
movie he's working on a trailer already
i go well i like the cast to see what
you know how the thing's coming together
and so they feel good about what we're
doing
and he's like yeah but we're losing time
and money and i said yeah i know but
just let it let us
he's he's almost done just let him
finish the trailer and then he'll get
back to editing
so okay cool so he spends like two days
on this trailer
and my producer's pissed and we get into
the room
and he's like i need to have a meeting
with you like okay just a second i bring
the whole cast in we're like
we own this we're in this hotel and
bring all the whole cast and crew in
there
i go stephen play the trailer plays a
trailer and everyone just loses it the
trailer just
nails everything i'm trying to do with
this movie and my producer's
very happy so he's like okay no worries
so i get back on monday i have that
trailer with me
and the producer she's hungarian very
tough she's a dear friend of mine now
she's a very tough
hungarian woman and i'm sitting in front
and she's like so why do why am i
meeting with you you're not with caa
you're not with william morris you're
not with this you're not with that why
am i even talking to you we're gonna pay
you as a writer why do you think you
should direct this
and i said well i just shot this film i
got back from i'd love
you to see the trailer of it wait i mean
you just shot it i go i just rapped
yesterday
she's like yesterday sunday i said yes
and you have a trailer already i said
yes
let me see so turn it around she's
watching the trailer and i just
she like folds my laptop down she looks
at me she's like
okay i go thank you appreciate your time
oh wow and uh she had another partner
actually and then she
called me and said i need to speak to my
partner first i said sure no problem it
was like a five minute conversation
after that and i got that gig
so i got that right after i got back
from so i was in post-production on
my fourth and in pre-production on my
fifth
and that was my best year man it was
just movie making non-stop
and uh yeah it was great and that
the fifth one they both got distribution
the fifth one got
picked up by uh lionsgate and was on
netflix it's actually
i just got word that it's making its
china debut this movie came out five
years ago
it's making its china debut in october
and its uk debut just last month
so that movie has still got legs it's a
boxing film it's a genre film so those
films kind of
they can go a little bit they go longer
they have a long shelf life
um so that was my my worst
and best years back to back and those
two
in themselves would be a book but i
managed to keep them to two chapters so
two very long chapters but what was your
takeaway of all that like just
from having those back to back i didn't
have time to think about anything
uh you know my i just didn't have time
to think about it i just felt like
i've been through the worst of it and i
got two more opportunities to do
something and then of course after
counter punch we screened counter punch
and my producers
from the fourth we're like now we we got
something do you have something for your
six i said yes and and then shot that
one in march of 2012.
you know so it's all started kind of
that those relationships started because
i i was building something with them at
least i thought i was building something
with them which was a troupe of actors
and everything else and then it just
started to rot from the inside out
and i had to walk away from all of that
everything i had built
because people had cheapened the entire
thing for their
own gain and for their own narcissism
and so since then you know as i started
over that's when i started marigold
and marigold was like i'm gonna do
something that nobody can copy
but some people tried to copy that as
well so
um but that movie hasn't uh i haven't
put that one out there as much because i
don't need to
i'm gonna wait until i can i can put it
somewhere where people will see it
but no hurry i've got other things i'm
writing i have six films out there i
have an incredible reel
i don't need to just put it out there
just to put it out there i love it too
much to just
stream it on amazon for you know
whatever you know anybody can do that
that's not distribution
you know i want it on netflix that's
where i want it i'm not even looking at
a theatrical i'm looking at just
netflix you know someone hang on to it
when did you start writing it which one
uh marigold
i didn't write anything it's completely
unscripted
okay yeah i mean that one i would say is
an outline i outlined i would come up
with scenarios and characters and i
would communicate those things to the
actors but they didn't have a script
it's improv
yeah so i i prefer unscripted only
because it sounds like there wasn't a
plan
there was a plan and there was a vision
we just weren't confined to
dialogue and it was really a tenuous job
for my editor
and she was a new editor that i i found
i love her to death because she
found the story and she crafted the
story and stayed with she stayed with me
with that movie for
a good two years and now she's working
on bigger and better things so i'm real
excited for her as well so i'm a
training ground for
people who are going to move on to
bigger and better things
one thing in my book i said you know one
thing i kept reading
from industry insiders and it bothers me
every time
is there three things to success and
that's be kind
be humble and help other people succeed
if you do those three things you're
gonna succeed in our business
and i just think that's such [ __ ]
because i'm like if those are the three
things that's what you'd
use to get into the business then your
journey wasn't very difficult
i go because my experience has taught me
that when i've been kind
i get taken advantage of when i'm humble
people don't take me seriously as a
filmmaker
and when i try to help other people they
end up just stepping using you as a
stepping stone very true
i'm not saying those are three things
you should be in life
but in this business if you're starting
from nothing
you're gonna have a very hard time in
this business but these are all people
that are
kind of had a foot in the door you know
what i mean that say these things
and when you already have a foot in the
door well those things will be valuable
to you because maybe that
everyone's used to dealing with an
[ __ ] but you're already somebody
you know and one of the so it's an agent
blog that i follow but i called him out
on that he didn't respond but
i was just kind of like i go your last
name is a famous last name you're the
son of a famous a
agent so you already have a door open
to you so being those three things maybe
that disarms people and they go
oh yeah okay but when you're successful
already absolutely that works because
everyone goes
oh wow they're so kind they're so humble
and they're helping other people
but you're already successful it's easy
nothing you're not going to lose
anything
by being that you know and especially if
most people are used to
[ __ ] in those positions but uh but
yeah i i i'm going out
yeah that's fine but i do agree with you
i think in life those are good rules
great i think i think in this business
if you're going to help somebody you do
it because you want to do it but yeah
there's not
i don't know yeah that could be a whole
another
yeah workshop and i think that people
that would
disagree and say that's being too
negative i think a lot of them probably
haven't been through a lot they're naive
in a negative way in terms of the
business
right if you want to do the right thing
and you want to
keep your word i think that's great what
about
in search of fairness in this business
and thinking that everyone's going to
play that way
well i would say this like whatever it
is
you're doing if you're a writer and
actor director there is the discipline
and the craft of doing those things and
learning
those things and constantly learning but
it's also
looking and learning and paying
attention to this as a business
um not in the sense that it will get you
jaded but to give you some type don't go
in naive
you know it is a business that's number
one you know i've gotten into major
discussions with distributors over my
posters because they weren't artistic
enough and i wanted an artistic poster
but they just want to put
danny trejo on the cover because that's
what's going to sell and
they're going to that's what they do
right so i have to kind of let that let
them do what they do they let me do what
i do which was make the movie but there
is no
there's no fairness in this business
there isn't and you can't
you have if you understand that going in
then you can i think deal with it a lot
better
but if you go in thinking it's
something's going to make sense
or your journey is going to make sense
or it's going to be
fair or the outcome is going to be fair
you're going to have a very difficult
time
um because there's there is nothing fair
you know i
i know actors that have come out here
and have been at it for 40 years
and are nev have never been a serious
regular i have actors have come out here
been out here 10 years
and are serious regulars is that fair
no but that's just the nature of the
business it attracts a lot of different
people from all over the world
that all have something to say and
that can actually be an empowering thing
because to me there's no one way to get
in
if you took a panel of five filmmakers
they would each
let's say five very successful
filmmakers each of them would have a
different way of how they got in
i don't think there are two story two
stories that are the same
of how people succeed in this business
you just have to find what your story is
and commit to your journey and try not
to make it like anybody else
but go in there with the understanding
of
how the business works to the best of
your ability and
unfortunately a lot of that experience
comes through failure
and so you have to look at that you know
i always say
you know the more no's i get it gets me
closer to a yes that's a true that's
pretty true statement
you know there are some emails i've sent
out that were not worded right when i
reached out to a show runner and it got
back to me
and i'm like you know what i probably
could have ordered that better
um but that's a learning thing i didn't
look at it as a negative i looked at it
as okay well maybe i should have
asked for that or maybe i shouldn't have
worded it that way or maybe i should
reach out directly to that person
um but i don't know that there's any
sort of just being a complete douche bag
in this business i don't know that there
are any little mistakes that you're
going to make that are going to be so
detrimental to your career
i've made a ton it hasn't kept me from
from
from producing writing and directing
because it's so democratized now you can
shoot one on your phone
and you can learn how to shoot one on
your phone you know what i mean
so it's like you don't know how you can
look it up how do i make a movie how to
make a short film
um so you have to constantly
reading and researching and and you got
to love it
even the warts you know because if you
don't it's just eat you it'll eat you
i've seen it happen to people and it's
not
it's not uh to good people because they
were so
uh eaten eaten alive at the fact that
it's not fair
this isn't fair i did all this work and
i sacrificed so much
this isn't fair why did their movie get
here
mine didn't
so if someone's in that loop it's late
at night it's
early morning they're waking up they're
like you know what this isn't fair but
if i stop
i don't get to do x y or z and i may not
get a laurel
and i may not get uh this publication to
pick me as their new top 25 for the
website
but yeah it's funny right because i'm
not that guy i've never been that guy
who's got a top 25 list
i'm not the guy that's you know the film
festival gaia
but i am the guy that's written and
directed several feature films
that's the guy i want to be you know so
those are goals and
interesting goals but if if you have a
short film and you're going all over the
world
like you know a friend of mine who's a
filmmaker who went to film school
had an award-winning short decided he
wanted to go to afi because he thought
he would make more connections that way
i go you already know how to make a
movie why are you gonna go and spend a
hundred thousand dollars to go to efi
well i'll make connections that way
and i'm like that's no guarantee man
yeah you'll meet some people but don't
you think everybody's going for that
reason
and i go just make something you know i
go
how much money did you spend going all
over the world with your film so we went
a ton of awards like oh yeah but didn't
get you the next project
i go i would have taken all that money
and made something with it you know so
um it depends what your priority is i
think if you're ego driven
you know maybe that's what drives you i
don't know i'm just not that person i'm
driven by storytelling
pure and simple i'm not a
multi-hyphenate either i i say write a
director
so people have some type of perspective
in terms of what i do but
essentially i just see myself as a
storyteller and
i'm using tools that i have at my
disposal to tell the stories that i want
to tell
and that's what drives me none of the
other stuff does
all the other stuff would be great you
know my very simple goal is just to make
a living as a writer director
that doesn't necessarily mean going to
sundance it doesn't necessarily mean
being rich and successful just means
making a living as a writer director
that's an attainable goal everything
else
if that happens that's all gravy but an
attainable goal for me is that
you know and your first time out you're
expecting
you know look around pay attention i'm
looking at
you know the hardest thing with marigold
and matador was i was making an
undistributable film
and i knew it it wasn't my first film it
was my seventh and i knew
it was undistributable and having to
keep going
because the itch would not go away on
telling this story
was very difficult whereas if i had the
naivety of a first-time filmmaker
would have plowed right through that
right because i'm making my first film
but i'm making my seventh and i'm broke
and i'm going why am i doing this
it's just something i have to do why was
it undistributable
um for many reasons i mean just going
from off my experience
it's you know it's about a single woman
there's a homeless character in it who's
schizophrenic
and it's like a coming-of-age story this
young girl it's an all-latin cast
takes place in la in what i call the
real l.a
um i just no stars are in it um camila
banus is in it she's
an amazing actor she's on days of our
lives but she's so good
she was so gracious to be a part of that
project that was my second time working
with her
um i just didn't
knowing the experience i had and what
distributors say i just didn't feel like
it was going to
find a buyer at least not right now
maybe later down the line
they will be you know we'll see
when cuaron's movie came out roma i
thought it's very
much shot in that vein not to that you
know that brilliance
obviously but there was a great movie
about a story about a woman
it wasn't a star and everything else and
did pretty well i think so
who knows but again i don't have the the
machine behind me
so i just have to sit and wait on that
one